hello my name is Jamie McAuliffe with
the education for employment foundation
we're an organization that provides
training link to jobs across the Middle
East and North Africa and partnership
with businesses and the private sector
and I'd like to say a few words about
some of the questions here one being
what is most important to change in the
region to create new jobs and I guess
the fundamental job creation mechanism
is confidence we need to build
confidence for businesses to invest in
the region for businesses to want to
grow and add employees and and that's
going to take all actors really having
confidence not only in the economy and
the politics and in the basic social
framework but also down to the local
level giving young people the confidence
that they can be trained up and get
meaningful employment with the right
support I think that what will most
accelerate growth in the Arab world is
really this focus that's been talked a
lot about here at the World Economic
Forum with true multi-sectoral
partnerships I think the CEO of
coca-cola Mukhtar Kent calls it the
Golden Triangle government civil society
and businesses working together to
identify solutions and accelerate
scale-up proven models education for
employment it was one such model and we
are tripling our growth over the next
three years to place six thousand young
people in jobs with more than 700 ployer
partners across the region so just one
small example of how our growth is
accelerating through this kind of a
multi-sectoral partnership
there's a big focus on entrepreneurship
in the Arab world and that is so
critical for job creation and it's going
to be a big part of these economies and
again for entrepreneurship to work in
this region as it needs to across the
world we need to develop the ecosystem
of supports for young entrepreneurs to
really connect to the resources they
need you know the most important thing
is not access to finance or skills it's
really building that confidence at a
young age that young people can be
problems all those creative thinkers and
then if they have an idea successfully
launch and grow a business so it's
instilling that confidence surrounding
them with people who will support them
the policy and business enabling
environment that won't get in their way
will provide incentives for
entrepreneurs to grow that's really
what's going to make a difference and
finally the question about how you can
make a difference well they're already
making a huge difference obviously in
the Middle East and North Africa as we
see a country after country and how you
can continue to make a difference is if
we listen to them if we engage them in
conversation we listen to our youth they
really are clients they tell us the
skills they need for a job and we train
them up as the as do we listen to
businesses but what they need so
listening to young people encouraging
them and providing them hope and
opportunity is what's going to make a
difference the revolutions that have
swept the region are not going to really
be fulfilled if that that hope and
optimism and passion is not met with
real solutions that will provide
economic opportunity for young people
and that's what efe and others here are
committed to doing